former olympic weightlifter tracy
lambrechts claims female athletes are
being told to be quiet
over any issues they have about
transgender people taking part in
women's competitions
whenever we have tried to speak up we've
been told that we can't say that
and anything we do say could potentially
lead to being taken to the human rights
court so we've been disencouraged every
step of the way and even to this day
athletes are still being told to be
quiet and not talk about it
laurel was a weightlifter before the
transition
so having transitioned in the 30s
that athlete would have still had the
benefits of testosterone
for 30 years so there's no way as a
woman we can compete against
a transgender athlete who's had the
benefits of testosterone
for that long even with having to lower
it
the lowered amount is still nearly 10
times the amount the average female
there's a reason why in sport we do have
male
and female categories and by allowing
this to happen it's just blurring the
lines
the shoes were first raised when
transgender athlete laurel hubbard was
allowed to compete as a woman before
transitioning in 2013 hubbard took part
in
men's weightlifting competitions later
in 2015 she was permitted to take part
in the olympics
after the ioc released rules for
transgender athletes allowing them to
compete as women
anyone who transitions from female to
male is allowed to compete with other
males without restriction
but those who transition from male to
female face certain conditions
firstly their gender status has to be
confirmed as female and mustn't have
changed for at least four years
the level of testosterone has to be
below 10 for at least 12 months
tracy lambrechts again thinks the rules
should be evolving as the sport does
it needs to be more research just
looking into the facts and making sure
that everyone is on the same page
whether or not the rules are fair that's
what needs to be discussed
these rules were i think um developed in
2013 or 2015
we're now in 2021 so i feel like the
rules should be evolving
as the sport does and as
people evolve because people are coming
out now more
transgendered and i think that we just
need to keep up with the times
why should i compete when i'm never
going to be able to win because
this is what i'm up against and i think
it
there is the potential to have women
dropping out of sport which which is not
what we want we want an increasing woman
playing sport
you